clear um our meeting open
so firstly i have an apology from uh
councillor wendy duty
no other apologies here so you appear to
move that nibble
seconded by l and we'll put that all
those in favor aye
the contrary carried any conflicts of
interest
okay we come to confirmation of minutes
um item 3.1
and someone prepared to move the notes
removed
council parts second to councillor
williams
what the recommend you wish to speak
well okay
you want anyone else what they're all
those in fact right
contrary carried any matters arising
all right so um i just got a late agenda
item and that's the delegations for
managing regulation if you've all
updated your
um diligence uh see things i see before
it's in there so we'll deal with h is
i'm proposing we deal with it as item um
5.3 so i just need to move that we
accept the latest gender item so i moved
from the chair
second account sub leki it's procedural
or i'll put that all those in paper
right
country carriage okay so now we come to
4.1 joey
good afternoon um this report
is um providing a summary and seeking
endorsement for the strategic approach
of the combined foundations of and rest
of network
business case which has been prepared by
the greater christchurch partnership
this is a culmination of several months
of work
on public transport in the greater
christchurch space
and it aligns with previous briefings
which have been provided by barry mayne
the recommended package of work for
mccarrary
includes increased expenditure and bus
shelter infrastructure
and also allows for some budget
operations
and all cost which includes tdm over the
next two years
i would just note in the recommendations
that we through the business case
proposes an annual increase in
investment from fifty one thousand
to two hundred and fifty thousand fifty
five thousand per annum
um at this stage in our draft long term
plan we have allowed for
105 000 per annum however this matter
would be considered further as part of
the long-term plan process
and that i'll take the report as read
and if there's any questions i'm happy
to answer them
thanks jerry any questions counsel
just looking at the um the
big report that sabacc um on page 77 of
our agenda sorry joanne um it just talks
about bus stop enhancements
and it talks about a connection stop a
a key stop and a minus stop but the
inference is that every single stop has
a bus
shelter what are we aiming at and what
as part of greater christchurch
yep that's a really good question and i
think the aim is definitely to provide
an increased level of service that
actually does encourage people
to take the bus and certainly on wet and
cold days
there's not a lot of encouragement for
people to stand out in the rain
and take the bus if they have nowhere to
stand
over time i think we would aim for the
air but it would
take time to get there i think what the
package of investment has
potentially allowed for that over the
10-year period
but the suggested expenditure at the
moment
wouldn't get us to a bus stop in every
location over there
so how many sort of are you aiming at
ballpark
um well if we looked at that it was
saying we've got half the expenditure we
will be able to probably do around half
of our stops over 10 years
but so that would be something for
council to consider it does also
i think depend on the number of people
who are accessing
via each stop so we would need to assess
that on a case-by-case basis
in terms of how big the shelters would
need to be
okay further questions council williams
yeah will we have the um full control of
how this money spent
or will it be dictated some of it
by other parties to the council
the funding will
have 51 funding through nzta via ecam
because it is part of public transport
we would need a process that prioritised
where our bus stops go and
i think a good starting point for that
would be around the patronage the number
of people getting on and off at each
stop
so i think we would use that as our
starting point for how we make decisions
around
which stops get prioritised first
for the questions we have a
recommendation some appear to move
well i'll move it oh sorry you can move
the council down that yeah
um second council brian council obama
yes um it's obvious looking at the
report that this is
something that we need to commit to the
amount of money we've been spending to
try and encourage people to use public
transport
is not going to cut the master in a
growing district so this is a sensible
investment and not too fast not too slow
uh trying to improve the level of
service to make it easy to travel by bus
and it is in line with what our partners
are doing so i thoroughly endorse
putting this in the plan
for the speakers well just just briefly
just to say that this is
we're the last of the partners to
receive this report and
um no it's just before christmas but
it's really important that we do
endorse this report today because uh it
is
when it goes through to the next phase
it would be great that all the
partnership
are an agreement with this general um
position and we've already had barry was
here not that long ago and
has briefed the council yes there is an
additional budget item but
as joanne's mentioned that something we
will consider have further opportunity
to consider as part of the long term
plan but
um i think all the work's been done on
this they've done a really good job so
i personally support it and like city
council endorse that today
you're the speakers i'll put the wreck
you wish to exercise your right reply
account savannah
okay i'll put the recommendation all
those in favor aye
thanks joanne we now come to
uh five five point one italy terrace so
uh it's raymond and
[Music]
sorry rob pardon me just hit a moment
[Laughter]
sorry rob don't easily forget you
all right all right
thanks guys raymond thank you
so um we received the application from
lime
development to store part of the elvi
terrace world
there are two legal framework we could
use
to stop the road one's a local
government act
the other one is public works act but in
this case
because after we stop the road we're
going to sell it to the electronic owner
it is better to use the local government
act
so
[Music]
this obviously is the one of the last
stages
of completing the connector road and
so it's a logical progression of things
that have been in front of council for
some years and is closing out on that
part of that
thank you we'll take the report as
having been read yes
but it was stations from the
transporter yeah it was part of
utilities rating last week so for some
of us we'll be still familiar with the
uh council williams question yeah
can you just um inform us
how we get the valuations of that do we
get the
value of what we sell that road portion
is the same as what we pay for existing
properties or
how's the formula worked out on what we
get per square metre
uh certainly it's um in the earlier
sales
um there was um two
lime there was a calculation that
effectively covered all of our costs
associated with the purchase of the
other properties the board property and
and the like in this instance
the roads wasn't subject to that and so
we would likely get
a valuation assessment of what the
general land values
were and that would take into account
the um capacity of that to be utilized
for
um the current zoning ozoning
and um so yeah so we'll be on a
valuation basis
um casa becky
item d rob on the um
recommendations what on what grounds can
people object to this
and what's the procedure if the if
anybody does
that graeme could use
my phone please thank you
so basically people who living surround
the
road surfing area can object that and
they have to have a valid reason um
it's not like a you know there's a
just random people say ah i don't agree
with the road stopping and we have to
consider it's not like that
we have to assess it internally
and if we uphold the
objection then it has to go through the
environment court
okay so any further questions
counselor i just just um
when it stopped there's a piece of road
there that's going to remain there
for obviously for the private residents
that are there that'll go to the
community board about the naming of that
what that should be i
don't think we've contemplated um that
question
um it's just it's been raised by a
neighbour there yeah
and i had heard that they were looking
at changing the name
rightly or wrongly and it is at the end
island road so that
you can put all those things together if
you like my question is can we have it
at
the end of that design of road if that's
possible can we look into that before
that's done yep
oh joey might be able to clarify do you
want to come to the table jane
thank you
uh if you could just use the mic for
adrian's benefit and the
audio stream or recording i was just
gonna say scott morrow
is all over that in terms of the naming
and he will be bringing the report back
to council
thank you any further any further
questions
for the recommendation some of you to
move
council williams secondary councillor
um redmond council williams do you wish
to speak
councillor edmund now the only comment
i'd make is i think stopping under the
local government act is preferable
because
then affected parties do have the
ability to object
and it's a transparent process so i'm in
favor of the
recommendation thank you any further
speakers
i'll put nothing to respond to i'll put
the recommendation all those in favor
please say hi
contrary we clear that carried thanks um
rob and raymond appreciate that thank
you
all right uh 5.2 so
uh mark and don
you're up thank you
could you she might be thanks thank you
thank you yes
um good afternoon everybody um this
report
is uh asking for a recommendation for
the approval of the construction
of the cycleway in the career and
parakeet street
i'll take the report as being read but
i'll just give a quick summary of the
work that we've done in the last couple
of months just for people
that potentially aren't aware of what's
happened in the project
in august we had a public meeting with a
large number of residents approximately
to 80 residents that had some concerns
about our proposed cycle way
it became apparent from that meeting
that there was a lot of confusion around
what potentially we were wanting to do
in the street
and people's misunderstanding of
the cycleway in general so at the
board's recommendation
staff went back to re-engage with
residents and this engagement was done
via a letter and to ask residents if
they would want to be interested
in participating in a working group and
the working group would consist of three
sessions
working with residents and key
stakeholders like the school
and fire service and cycling advocates
to
look at the design that work
was done through the month of october
and november
and while we were working through the
working group process
and listening to residents concerns and
educating them on the design
also we also sent a flyer and a survey
out to all residents in vicari and
paraki street
to update them on the um the process the
design and give the residents the
opportunity to talk to us again because
they felt that they hadn't been hurt
their voice hadn't been heard
we collated that work from the survey we
additionally did a public
church meeting with residents to
socialize our
refined designs and also listen to their
concerns
all that work ultimately was brought
back into
refining our design where we tried to
remove as many of the issues from
residents concerns from our design as
possible
and come up with a design that we felt
was not only safe but also
mitigated a lot of the concerns around
lost parking and residence issues around
intersections
so the work really then was
refined down to a point where we had a
reasonable amount of
consensus from the working group not
everyone in the working group agreed
with our design ultimately
and yeah we got to a point where we felt
that we had addressed
and engaged as much as possible with
that work
ultimately i guess from this report
we're looking at either two options one
is to go ahead with the design
and the other i suppose it's to abandon
practice street and potentially look
elsewhere
the concerns around if we don't go ahead
with the design will be
that we have we would not be meeting
potentially our our obligations with
a wider christchurch and the
christchurch northern corridor
we wouldn't have a um a link through
kype where the link would basically stop
at the edge of kaipur and also
um the passenger path so riders would be
left to navigate their own way through
the town
so we feel that that the design would
would benefit not only kaipor but the
wider community of
waimakariri as well i guess if we
weren't to go ahead with the project
some residents would feel that they have
been listened to
and their concerns have been addressed
but i think the survey results from the
survey that we did with
the wider residence shows that there is
a very low
turnout of residents that were against
the project after the refined designs
as opposed to the initial august
consultation
so we think that we've got considerably
more approval
from the residential survey and
responses from the people um
i guess that in summary is the lot the
work's happened in the last two months
i'm happy to take any questions on the
report
thanks mark did you wish to add anything
don
thank you questions councilman
just one quick question all the
modifications and additional things that
residents have asked for are they going
to cost
more um no actually interestingly enough
um so one of the probably the major uh
concerns residents with speed humps
um so the speed humps were single with
humps and we were trying to
i guess beautify the street by putting
in some landscaped areas with plantings
and trees
now the feedback from residents was that
the lost parking um for them
and single lane humps were something
that they weren't really interested in
so probably almost halving the price of
those speed humps is by removing the
planters
making an asphalt hump you can park over
those humps although
i wouldn't kind of suggest that you
should it is done so we
we basically have kind of almost removed
those issues around
the parking and there's been a cost
saving there as well across six speed
hunts
thank you any further questions i've got
a recommendation
i'll move it see the council backing
um
i think it's been a very interesting
exercise to say the least
and i think the attachments speak volume
for the work that's been done
on this particular project to meet with
both the residents and it was certainly
at the public meetings and others and
i've had
a number contact me concerned about the
process that the council
has followed there but i think the work
that's been done particularly and that's
not to
draw any conclusions about the past
because i know that was work was being
done but
in the later part the work that's been
done there is
has really worked really hard to try and
bring
the community on site and to i guess
address the concerns that have been
uh been raised and i would really like
to commend
you mark and don uh karen and team
who've been involved
uh for that week because i think and
sandra is the independent chair i have a
few good feedback there around that
process that's been being followed in
the committee that's obviously been
supporting that
i think it's a really important link
to lincoln with the other work that's
been a significant investment from nzta
obviously they were a major part in this
investment too but
the thing that really interested me when
we were went to the open day of the
northern corridor was just how many
people were out there on their bikes and
using this area
and the excitement that is generally
around the community around the cycling
i think it's going to be very popular
and there does need to be a safe path i
acknowledge that not everyone is
universally happy but i think on balance
what swayed me is the work that's gone
on to address the resident's concern and
to try and come up with a solution
that's a win-win
really but acknowledge not everyone is
going to be entirely happen but happy
but
when i looked at the numbers there were
roughly 50 50.
it's a big difference from the 90 odd
percent that were opposed um before
so just mark i'd like to say thank you
for particularly your work and leading
this i
understand you're retiring from it or
moving on from the council
i wish i was retiring but you're not
retiring but you're um
you know i would just like to say i
thank you for your service uh and all
the work that you've put into this
cycleways do tend to engender bits of
comments and i have talked to other
councils around and how they're dealing
with these things
and so we we have had some discussions
around the
perhaps ways that we can undertake
consultation and what are the learnings
from other
councils and from our own processes and
how we bring people more on board and i
think
what we've ended up with now is a really
good blueprint for consultation so thank
you for that
this is a recommendation that's come
through from our community board
uh so it's been through that exercise
and on that basis plus the work that's
been done i'm prepared to support it
uh counselor becky
for the speakers council debate that's
right
counselor stuart who else put their hand
up counselor movement
just very quickly often um proposals
like this
engender a lot of fear and so it is very
very important to acknowledge that fear
and to bring people along with you and
you've done a spectacular job of doing
that by the look of all the information
we've seen in the report and i think
what residents may find is it's not as
bad
as it turns out and it's often the fear
of the unknown
as to what happens i've had friends live
in peraki street and
the boy racer problem has been nasty
through there so i actually think that
some of these measures will actually
make life nicer for them
but it is really important to
acknowledge that on-street parking is
really really important for residents
that they do want people to visit and so
on so we've got to keep that balance in
mind
so i think you've done a very very good
job with all the group that's been
involved to get this all over the line
thank you
council stuart thank you um
i certainly congratulate um both
yourself mark and don
on on your dedication and determination
to get the recommendation
that we're going to approve
today um i'm particularly
interested in um uh
having a report and i i guess there's a
question there
are we going to have a report on what
went well
what didn't go well and how we approach
issues like this in the future because
we're going to have plenty of them
and you know while
this is a uh has turned out successfully
you know the fact that i don't even
actually can't even add up how many
roman numerals there are and attachments
here but
um that's not what you want to see
so is there going to be a report because
it's all very well to say look we've
learned that this perhaps isn't the way
to do it
um we've ended up where we would like to
have
gotten potentially at a cheaper
cheaper price but we need to have a
template on how we should do it in the
future so
is there a written report coming in
mark's knowledge before you um
you leave would be really welcome
because
i think that we need a new template for
um addressing issues like this we're
going to have plenty of them and
i would agree with the sentiment
expressed that
um there are going to be plenty of
people coming across that
that cycle way from christchurch on
saturday morning when i went through i
thought
how many are on it and there were three
coming just
uh early morning and i thought well here
we are they're already
people are already using it so we're
going to have um
other issues um come up other proposals
so
are we going to have a look at our
template for
consultation on these and how we can do
it
much better than we've ended up having
to do it
here so just briefly missed me i've
booked in a session i i certainly picked
up on councillor stewart's
similar comments at the kai boy
community board we're booked in a
session tomorrow before mark does go
where we are going to have a debrief
with at the staff level as to what meant
well what didn't go so well and what we
can do in the future and we will be
bringing that back firstly to the cowboy
community board and then on
uh on from there thank you
council redmond
thank you mr mayor i think there have
been learnings in this exercise
initially i opposed the cycleway down
pirachy street based on the level of
opposition
from residents and i say residents
because i would put residents
rights first really i think
they have a vested interest in their
property in their street they were
concerned with loss of parking
loss of amenity and other
factors i sort of kept in the background
but kept in touch during this
extended process which i'm pleased to
say went very well and i've received
very complimentary reports about mark
and don and the team
so i think it is important that we're
transparent when we are trying to
persuade
perhaps people to a certain point of
view um
i thought i'd just read a sentence
from bruce hogart who was one of the
original
um organizers of the public meeting
initial public meeting and he agreed
that a better outcome will have been
achieved with the help of the little
residential
activism as he refers to it
i hope that the council outcome provides
a safe
accident-free piracy street and
he said
somewhere here really saying
in order to effect an abandonment of the
cycle way down piracy stream
substantial support was needed for most
of the residents
and this was lacking in the final survey
so whilst not everyone will be happy i
think there has been
significant progress in getting a number
of residents over the line
and on that basis i'm
happy to support the proposal
and it is something to bear in mind when
we do consult on cycleways
it's not just cyclists we need to
consult with really
it's to look at it from the resident's
point of view as well
and i look forward to the outcome of
your debrief
and once again thank you very much as i
said at the community board perhaps
unofficially
this parakeet strength cycle way may be
known as the mark barton cycle one
but that's unofficially the barn's way
thank you very good any further speakers
uh there's nothing really to respond to
other than to just to acknowledge the
comments that have been made
already around stuff i think the debrief
as i mentioned in my
the comments i think will be really
important actually those learnings that
we
have picked up i don't think our process
was totally flawed but it certainly was
um it started pre-during a
pre-covered period and then there was
all that period of time in between so
there
are um and there will always be no
matter how hard we try
uh people that feel that they haven't
got communication in those but it's
really useful to
learn from that and how we can pick
those items up for future consultations
because cycleways
will engender conversation no matter
which where they go but i i do think
that they're a good thing in our
district for people to be safe in their
cycling
and i know that a lot of people are
looking forward as we mentioned to use
it
coming from rangura through uh kaiapoi
uh and uh later i do hope that we do get
a link from woody
at a particular point in time through
the guidebook because i do think that
people will use it more often
intending to have a go during the
christmas period myself on my bike
from rengura which will be good for me
um but i um
i just i think that's the sort of level
of excitement that we do and interest
that we do have in our district going
forward and i think
likewise from the city side we're going
to have a lot more
um locals from from canterbury coming
through which is really great but thanks
again mark for all your work de don
karen all the teams have been involved
it's really appreciated i'll put the
recommendation always in favor please
say aye
contrary to clear that carried
there we are the barnes way
or all the best with your future mark
thank you
cheers
cheers i was right reply
i moved it i'm sorry
okay thank you okay thank you i i asked
if there were any further speak i'm
happy to let you speak if you wish
that's all right i asked for further
speakers sorry
about it yeah thanks team
all right
all right so we now come to um 5.3 which
is the additional
agenda item so just give you a minute to
pull that and
from your agenda
so that's the delegations for the
manager of regulation
yeah yeah
sorry did you did you want to offer
something soon
yeah that's right just
just remember that other cheers quite
often forget to
even afford the right opportunity to
speak
just saying
[Laughter]
just just just remember that that's all
i have to say
all right um jim thank you thank you mr
mayor and thank you for your indulgence
receiving this late
report thought uh given that there's a
regulatory separation that occurs
in the council between the chief
executive and the head of regulation
in this case manager of regulation it's
appropriate to ensure that
through the transition between nick's
retirement and tracy teeny's
commencement in february that
should the need arise we've got somebody
who has the delegation in place and that
doesn't become
it doesn't trip us up in any action that
we might want to take and
we hope that there is there are none to
be taken but in the case that there are
this report suggests that uh
yep um i'll see matt's in the room um
matt bacon
is yep you'll do that
yep matt matt and the manager planning
implementation unit
uh manager would be appropriate to hold
that delegation for that period so
uh just seeking your indulgence to
endorse that please
thank you any questions moved council
atkinson seconded
sorry council do you speak i'm just very
pleased that the uh
ce wrote that in as he was sitting there
just the name
just seen you were here no look it'll be
great to have met there um just looking
after things while things
took over for the next month or two so
we definitely need it and uh i hope
everyone will support it
it's just good to see that this hasn't
caused the chief executive
some headaches and over this period of
time it's very important that we have
a delegation here and it's nice to just
have that tidied up before christmas
so thank you council meetings
in addition to the aforementioned
comments i just like to say um
matt i think you're the perfect person
for the job and i'm glad you're here to
um
hold the reins for us well done
any further speakers counselor
[Laughter]
all right um right of replying council
renkinson
i'll put the recommendation all those in
favor please say aye
contrary to clear that carried so uh
with that
um our next meetings to be held on the
2nd of february at 1pm we have another
meeting at
3 so to clear it
thanks matt happy christmas
clear our meeting clays thanks adrian